How long ago How long ago did you
convert to Islam?
Uh about 2 1/2 years ago.
Okay. Okay. Where'd you convert from?
Were you an atheist, Christian?
Uh I was a Christian before.
Oh, okay.
>> Um I So, I mainly wanted to just ask you
guys like three questions if possible. I
don't really want to debate cuz I kind
of think um
debates aren't necessarily the best.
Yeah, we can we can talk. We can talk it
out. Yeah. You can you can ask three
questions as long as you grant me three
questions.
Sure, yeah. I think that's good.
All right. All right. Um
So, my first question is
you know, I've been looking at like
Islamic and Christian polemics,
like how they kind of debate,
and it kind of seems like more
people both from the Muslim side and the
Christian side
convert to atheism rather than like if
they're going to leave their faith,
right? Rather than converting to the
other.
Um So, I was wondering like
for me as a Muslim, I see more priority
in
maybe doing Dawah to atheists, like
against atheism,
rather than against Christianity. I was
wondering what you guys think of that in
terms of
against Muslims as well. It seems like
atheism is kind of more like a prominent
threat against God
just in general.
Nope. I think
>> think Do you think more Christians are
converting
>> to receive it.
Do you think more Christians are
>> converting to
Islam or atheism of the ones that leave?
Uh I I wouldn't know. I didn't I didn't
look at that. But um
if you're just asking me my my personal
view,
um I think that Islam is more dangerous
than atheism.
Um Islam is a is an actual
threat to society and to living with
your neighbors.
But what about in terms of like actual
Christians leaving the faith? It seems
like atheism is more of a threat in that
regard. It
It's not.
>> [clears throat]
>> I think anything is a threat, but
they're both like they both need to be
preached against and they're both false
and that Christianity is the only way.
Yeah, okay. I get that. I was just
wondering what you guys thought of that.
Um that that was the first question.
Um my second question, this is honestly
just to get a better understanding.
Um
So, I know there's a verse in the Bible
where
uh it tells like the women to cover
their hair, like those who pray. Mhm. I
was wondering what how you guys
interpret that verse, like
like what do you think of the hair cover
or the head covering from based off that
verse and how how would you interpret
it?
Yeah, well, there was specific people in
the specific church.
We see it in Timothy and also in
Corinthians that there was a woman
disobeying the elders of the church and
they were speaking out. And so, he told
them to do it as sort of a humbling to
the woman in the specific church saying,
"Hey,
you guys are speaking out. You need to
humble yourselves." And this is the
reason why he instilled it in them. Uh
it's a good thing to do. You know, you
can choose to veil and cover your head
in church if you want, but it's not
necessary for everyone to do cuz again,
it was employed for a specific people
group for specific um uh sort sort of a
consequence in a sense for what they
were doing.
Um So, it wasn't like something that was
like a rule to be applied like
>> Not like a universal rule, no. Like we
don't believe like today like you can't
go to church if you
don't wear a head covering.
Okay, it's interesting cuz I went I went
to an Orthodox church uh a few times and
some of the women did wear head
coverings there. They They were under
the impression that while you're in
church, you should wear it.
Yeah, I mean, I I am Orthodox, so yeah,
I go to Orthodox church, too. Um yeah,
some women do in church. Some don't.
You'll You'll never find a priest not
allowing communion though to anyone not
wearing a head covering or not allowing
any woman to enter or pray, etc.
That's not
>> You also wouldn't consider it sinful if
they didn't. Correct. I don't think it's
a sin if they don't wear a head covering
in church, no.
Okay.
Um All right, thank you. Uh I guess the
last question I had was I was wondering
if you guys saw uh Sonny Fahlz's
documentary.
No.
>> [clears throat]
>> Oh, you didn't see it? Okay.
Well, that's that's my three questions.
Okay.
>> They might not be the ones you're
expecting, but that's kind of what I
wanted to ask you guys. Uh you just you
just sounded curious, so that's that's
cool.
>> honestly curious, bro. Yeah.
All right, so my first question. Ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Okay.
What convinced you
that Islam was true?
Uh [sighs]
well,
I would say as a foundation,
um
the theology of Islam, so mainly the
oneness of God,
uh
is the I believe it's the only rational
conclusion
based off of what we observe in the
world. So, I think that coming to the
conclusion that there is a God who is
immaterial and that he's all powerful
and he's all knowing
and that he's not part of creation, that
he's one,
um makes the most sense. And then from
there, I I I think that when we look
around the world, you know, everything
has a purpose.
You know, the chair you sit on has a
purpose. The animals have a purpose. The
trees have a purpose.
And I think it would be
peculiar if if God left us on this this
world without any guidance or any
purpose.
So then from that point,
I basically looked at the Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
and
things that he did, like um the way that
the Quran was became from an illiterate
man,
and then the prophecies that he had, um
some of the miracles surrounding the
Quran,
those types of things.
And then in that and then in combination
with the theology,
Okay. those are the kind of the main
reasons [music] and obviously we can go
deeper in there.
Yeah, I I want to go a little deeper cuz
you said you converted from
Christianity, so Yeah. you you said what
was important to you was that there was
the teaching of one God, immaterial,
right? Beyond his creation.
That's what That's what Christianity
teaches.
And he's and that he's given us guidance
and instruction on how to live and stuff
through his scriptures.
So, Christians do believe though that
God part partook in creation in some
sense though. So does Islam.
How how so?
Oh, man.
In many ways.
>> saying Islam teaches that that God is
part of creation or became part of
>> No, not that he's part of creation, but
that he partakes in creation.
Yeah, if you mean like he influences
creation, that's I agree, but I'm saying
like Christianity Like he enters
creation. He enters creation. Like he
enters and interacts with creation.
>> I don't I I don't know if it's physical.
Depends on which Muslim you ask, but we
see like for example, you see there's
there's a there's there's Hadith that
talks about how Allah
descends to the lowest heaven at every
at the third of every night, right? So,
that's him going from one place to
another. He's descending, meaning he's
going down and he's going, so he's in
creation. He goes to creation and sits
and asks, "Who's praying to me? Who's
praying to me?" right? Um
Yeah, if I if I can say something to
that real quick.
Um I don't interpret that to be literal.
I don't believe that like like Allah
literally is like a body that comes down
into the sky.
Um I think that's just a metaphor. Uh
So, we have something in like Quran
interpretation that's called the Tanzih,
which is you take the clear verse
over the ambiguous verses.
And the clear verse in the Quran it's in
uh Surah Al-Ikhlas. It says that he is
not comparable to anything like
creation.
So, we don't say that he is like
creation in any sense.
Um so, by making
>> sense?
Yeah, in any sense.
He's absolutely dissimilar from
creation. Yeah, that that that's
confusing to me because there's too many
ways that the Quran describes Allah to
his creation in a in in a lot of senses.
Like he It says that Allah is light and
his light is like a lamp and like the
olive and like the tree and you know,
like have you have you read Surah Surah
24?
Yeah, I've I've read it. So, it it like
it
>> You know what I'm saying?
It does liken him
>> It likens him to creation in some sense.
So, to say to say no senses is a little
confusing.
>> No, not really. Um
So, the thing is about
those verses is that they're speaking
very poetically.
Um that's the first thing. Like
when it says things like Allah
is on his throne or he has like a right
hand or whatever, these types of things,
um
I don't interpret these to be literal if
that makes sense.
>> on what basis though? Like that's what
I'm saying cuz I I understand that, but
on what basis are you saying this isn't
literal? Like he doesn't actually have
hands or he doesn't he doesn't actually
descend or he doesn't actually, you
know, do what the Quran is You remember
you said clear verses. Were these verses
clear and explicit in what he's doing?
>> No, they're not clear because would you
agree that if a verse said that Allah
has a hand that you could possibly
interpret it literally and you could
also possibly interpret it
metaphorically?
Sure. So, then that means that there's a
range of of possible meanings, right?
What So, but what this is where I think
that he can't be interpreted
metaphorically. Like for example, where
he says that he made Adam with his
hands, right? Which is why he's special
and condemns Iblis for not bowing to
him.
Right? So, wouldn't that mean that that
that's cuz cuz remember if we're like
usually we'll hear maybe hands like has
to do with power or or authority, right?
>> Yeah.
Uh but that's how he created everything.
He created everything with his power and
authority. But specifically Adam, he
says, "Why didn't you bow down to Adam
whom I created with my own hands?"
Right? So that's a that's a There's
something special about how he created
Adam with his hands as opposed to
everything else he didn't create with
his hands.
So wouldn't that lead to the same thing?
>> that he didn't I see what you're getting
at, but I don't see how you come from
that verse that he's specifically saying
he only created Adam with his hands.
He's he's just simply saying that he did
create Adam with his hands.
>> So so why would why would he bring that
detail out if that wasn't special?
Because that's what it it's
communicating that why didn't you bow
down to Adam whom I created with my own
hands?
Like what what is If he created
everything with his own hands, what what
why is that special?
Well, it might not be particularly
special in in that instance.
I think so.
That and that's the difference. Like if
if I have a
let's say I have kids or something like
that, right? Let's say I have three
kids.
Um
and [clears throat] I say um
and I gave my my youngest or I gave my
oldest the
a nice robe.
And
I told I told the other brothers or I
told one of them,
"Uh why didn't you listen Why didn't you
listen to my son whom I gave
a gold robe to?"
Wouldn't that statement signify that me
giving him the gold robe is special and
unique to the other sons that I have?
Did I Did I pass that?
>> mean I I can see what you're saying. Um
I don't understand though how
So maybe if he is making a distinction
that he made him with his hands, I still
wouldn't give it the literal
interpretation.
Why? So so what would that mean then?
Cuz if he created everything with his
hands,
right? Or his power and his authority.
He created everything with his power and
authority. So there's something
different about when he says with both
my hands.
>> I I think what it's meaning is that
every other human is created through
the like the agent of another of their
mother, right? Um
and the difference with Adam is that he
was created directly with no
human descendant from him. Like he was a
straight from God in that sense.
Um
that's the distinction that I see
between Adam and and other people.
So as
>> But no there there there were no other
people there. He's talking about his
creation. He says, "Why didn't you bow
down to Adam whom I created with my own
hands?" Yeah, so what's distinct between
Adam and all the other humans is that he
was created without a father and a
mother, right? We're not talking We're
talking about in the moment when he
Iblees didn't bow down to him. There
were no other humans to compare him to.
He's being compared to He's being
compared to
>> realize the Quran was revealed after he
all these humans existed and That's
fine, but it's talking about a moment
where the other humans didn't exist.
That's the time frame it's it's
recounting.
Yes, but the time frame in which he said
that he that he mentions that he created
Adam with his hand is in the time of
Prophet Muhammad, correct? Right?
I don't I don't understand how that's
relevant. Well, it's relevant because
cuz you're saying that there wasn't
other humans at that time.
So let me get this straight. Do you
believe that there were other humans
when Allah created Adam and told Iblees
to bow down to him?
No, no. I don't.
>> Okay. So like Do you see how irrelevant
that is? So talking about other humans
Was there other humans Was there other
humans when he revealed that verse?
Sure. That doesn't matter.
No, [snorts] because that's when he's
making the comment. Okay. So did Allah
say to Iblees Did he say this when other
humans were around or did he say this
way before he created other humans?
May Can you maybe pull up Can you tell
me the reference of the verse so I can
see it?
>> Chapter 7, verses 11 and 12.
Let's see.
Uh chapter 7, verses 11 to 12?
>> 11 11 11 and 12, I believe. Yeah.
And we said
And we said prostrate except Iblees, he
was not among the prostrate. Let's see
12.
What prevented you from prostrating when
I commanded you? I am better than him.
Okay, then that's not the one.
Um there's a few of them. I forget the
other references. Where is Where is the
other reference at? I don't feel like
using Google, but I'll use it.
Um
I didn't
I created
with
What's the one that you already have?
Seven.
So then you need
Surah 30?
Surah 30, verse what? 38 verse 75.
38 verse 75? Yeah.
S- Barakallah alafik.
Hey, I'm going to count as achievement
that I made God Logic have to pull up
Google.
>> [laughter]
>> Man, I always got to do this, man.
My brain My brain don't be braining all
the time, man. Guys, maybe he's using
ChatGPT. Look, he's using ChatGPT.
>> [gasps]
>> Let's 38
video what?
38 video called
God Logic used ChatGPT mid-debate.
ChatGPT, man, I had to do it, y'all.
Sorry.
You know what I'm saying?
You know, when all else fails
Okay, yeah, there we go.
Yeah, so
um
What's the verse?
Oh, yeah. Chapter So chapter 38 verse
75.
Allah said to Allah said, "O Iblees,
what prevented you from prostrating
uh to that which I created with my
hands? Were you arrogant or were you
among the holy?" So you see this is
clearly something unique to Adam. He
didn't do He didn't create anything else
with his hands. This is Adam
specifically.
Yeah, I see what you're saying.
So I didn't I didn't realize that it was
he was quoting saying that at that time
that's what he told Iblees. I thought he
made that comment
uh I understand. I understand what
you're saying.
>> Okay.
Um I get what you're saying.
Uh me personally, I don't know
what exactly that means.
Sure.
>> but I can tell you this that I don't
believe that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has
literal material hands. I can tell you
that.
>> a There's a feedback on the mic. Is that
you, Nick? Yeah, it's you, Nick.
There's something coming out of your
mic.
Is there something blowing or something?
I don't think so. I just mute.
Yeah. Dang, that's crazy. I don't know
what happened.
Something was like It was like Yeah,
there it is.
Bro, what the heck? You hear that,
Aaron? Yeah, I hear that.
It's not me.
>> mute until I talk. I don't know. It's
not It's not Aaron. It's It's It's
definitely Feared Logic.
>> it's me. I I just mute until I talk. I
don't know. It's weird. Okay. Holy
Spirit.
>> [laughter]
>> Come on, bro.
All right. So
We have So all right, so you said you
don't know what that means, but you
won't conclude that that's like he has
actual hands. And so there's So my
question is based on what? Because it's
Look, this is a clear verse. It says he
he has hands. That's a clear verse. It's
not ambiguous.
So Well
>> Why why not believe what it says that he
has hands?
>> I still think it is
ambiguous.
Um to say that it's absolutely clear Are
you saying that You're saying that
there's no possible like the only
unequivocal interpretation of that is
that Allah literally has a hand?
Uh yeah, that's what it seems.
Yeah. Well, let me let me pull up the
verse. Okay.
>> I can't think of any any reason to to
think otherwise.
I'll tell you what. Go If you go to um
Surah Ikhlas, I believe it's the 112th
chapter,
um verse 4.
Yes, there's none like him in creation,
right?
Yeah, there's absolutely nothing
comparable to him. Right. So just to say
>> would say base Just to answer your
question real quick. Base The reason
that I interpret those other verses
metaphorically is because
that verse in Surah Ikhlas is absolutely
clear. No one disputes that meaning. Do
you watch NBA at at all?
Uh no, I don't usually watch NBA. Okay.
But do you know who the basketball
players are at least? The like the the
popular ones?
Steph Curry is a household name. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, I know them. Okay. I'm more
of an NHL, but yeah. I got you. If Is Is
there to your knowledge Is there a
shooter that is comparable to Steph
Curry?
Uh
>> [sighs]
>> man, I'm I'm sorry, but I really do not
watch basketball though. The answer The
answer's no. The answer's no, bro. He He
is He is literally like I would think
that God made him with his own hands and
said, "Go. Play. Shoot. Shoot the ball.
That's That's your mission." All right?
So there's there's not a single shooter
on the planet, at least of what we know
of, that is comparable to Steph Curry.
Does that mean nobody else can shoot the
ball?
No.
People can shoot, but they can't shoot
like Steph Curry.
That doesn't mean nobody else has the
ability to shoot or can shoot.
Right? So
>> Yeah. In saying that
there's nothing comparable There's no
shooter comparable to Steph Curry, it
doesn't mean that nobody else can shoot.
They can still shoot, just not to his
level.
In the same way, you can say that
there's nothing comparable to Allah
in like the absolute sense. Like That
doesn't mean that he doesn't have any
relation
or connectivity with with uh mankind.
>> Yeah, like Like for example, I mean I
would agree. I would agree cuz like
Yeah. to a to a certain extent
like I know in the it's more of a
Christian concept that humans are
created in the image of God. Nope.
That's a That's an Islamic concept, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Well
No, it's not. It's not an Islamic
concept.
>> Brother Brother Brother, you going to
learn to trust me, bro.
You going to learn to You going to learn
to trust me, bro. Look, let me show you,
man. Um I I think I know what you're
going to pull up. What do you think?
What do you think? You're going to pull
up the one where he created Adam in his
image. There you go.
Yeah, he created It It doesn't mean he
created Adam in Allah's image. It means
he created Adam in his
>> do this to me.
Don't do this to me, man. They they they
got you, huh? That Listen, that is the
That is the like That's the consensus
understanding.
>> No, it is not. The
No, the consensus understanding is that
Allah is Adam is made in Allah's image.
However, that doesn't mean that he is
like like Allah in in in in every way,
but that he has similar attributes in
that he's a thinking being. He has
will and
qualities.
>> Uh you might be talking to some some
Salafi people. I don't know.
Uh what Who are your scholars?
Who? Like by name?
Yeah, like or like who are some like who
scholars that you appeal to?
Um you mean like like online ones?
Maybe or Brother, like you said the
consensus of scholars. Like who who are
the scholars that you talk to or listen
to because Oh, like I could send I could
send you one.
Um
Like do you know do you know uh Dr.
Shadee Elmasry?
No. Are Are you a Sunni?
Yeah, I'm a Sunni. What are you if
you're not Salafi? Like Maturidi or
what?
Um I hate to put labels on it, but I
would say I align more with
with Ash'ari.
So, dude,
look, guys. Let me show everybody what
we're talking about. Cuz this is
There's There's no way you can think of
it in in any other way, man. So, Sahih
Muslim 2612E
is one of them, one of many.
This hadith has been translated on the
authority of Abu Hurairah, yada yada
yada yada, right? Uh Allah's Apostle
report is reported to have said, "When
any of you fights with his brother,
he should avoid his face,
for Allah created Adam in his own
image."
Yeah, Adam has his own unique image.
>> No, Allah Allah created Adam in his
Allah's image. That's why you shouldn't
hit your brother in the face.
It's not what it says. It says
>> So, then why in the world should you not
hit your brother in the face?
Why would you not hit anyone in the
face? Yeah, why is he permitting you
What Why is he prohibiting you from
hitting your brother in the face?
Why is he
I mean, because you you're not supposed
to destroy someone's face. Nope, that's
not the reason he gives.
He says, "For," meaning because Allah
created Adam in his own image."
Why is this important?
>> Yeah, I'm just going to I'm just going
to disagree with your interpretation.
I'm It's not I'm not interpreting it.
I'm reading it, bro. What? Yeah, and the
way I read it, I come to a different
conclusion.
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
Well,
um
Well, I think you got one more question
for me, right? Well, I got I had two,
but I think that
>> you definitely asked me like five
questions now.
>> Cuz we went deeper in the first one.
All right. Okay.
So,
we see that Allah has you know, he he he
has his acts within creation. He
interacts with creation.
Um
He can even take shapes of creation
according to Muhammad. Are you familiar
with that?
I'm just going to appeal to uh
the clear verse which says that he's not
[clears throat] comparable and he's not
like anything in creation. Okay, so
let's deal with this then.
>> Which is the other verses in uh
I believe it's
I forgot what verse it is. I can pull it
up though.
Uh huh
um
Yeah, Surah Ash-Shura 42. It's chapter
42:11. There is nothing whatsoever like
him. He is the all-seeing all or
all-hearing all-seeing.
So, what does that mean that there's
nothing
like him?
Well, it just means that he's not
comparable to creation.
What does that mean though? Because I'm
seeing ways that he is comparable. He
has hands, he has a shin.
He talks, he has mercy.
>> Again, those are those aren't literal.
They're not physical material.
>> I'm just saying. I'm I'm seeing these
clear verses like you're saying, you
stick with the clear verses. No, but you
already agreed with me that they can
have multiple possible meanings. Not the
one where he created Adam with his
hands. I didn't agree that there's
another meaning for that.
But I'm talking about the other ones you
you told me they have other possible
meanings. No. As for that one For
example, his shin That one still has
possible meanings. Just because he makes
What's the other possible meaning for
his for his shin?
What Which verse are you specifically
referring to? Chapter
um
chapter 60
eight. 68:42.
68:42
Yeah, so with all of these verses,
um
like for example, like the one with
Allah's hand, like it says Allah's hand
is over the believers.
Um that one for example, the context is
that they were doing a contract and he
revealed that verse to show that he was
fine with the contract and that he was
permitting the contract. And he used
that expression to do it. So, as for
this one
>> that got to do with the shin?
Yeah, so we can I mean, we can read the
tafsir.
Read the tafsir? The The The verse says
that he has a shin, right? That he's
going to reveal?
It said It doesn't say he has a shin. It
says the shin of Allah will be bared.
So, does it say he has a shin?
It doesn't say he has a shin. So, whose
shin is it?
It's the shin No, I agree it's the shin
of Allah. They got you, man. They got
you, bro.
You still haven't You still haven't
proven to me how how it means a literal
material shin. No, what you need to do
is show me
what else is it other than the shin when
it said What it What What is a It's a
metaphor.
It's a metaphor? Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> And and that's based off the other two
verses I gave you.
>> [laughter]
>> All right, let me show you something.
This is Sahih Bukhari on the Day of
Resurrection how you're going to see
Allah, all right?
And watch what this says. So, I I'm I
skipped a little bit to get to the
relevant part, but if you want context,
it's talking about how people will see
Allah and um how he's going to get rid
of the Jews, the Christians, and the
polytheists for what they worship.
They're going to follow what they
worship and go with them, all right?
And then we get down to here where the
Muslims are left, okay?
Sahih Bukhari 4581 says, "Then the Lord
of the worlds will come to them," to the
Muslims.
Will come to them
in a shape nearest to the picture they
had in their minds about him.
Yeah.
How is it that Allah is going to appear
in a shape
that
um
matches what they pictured about Allah
in their brains, in their minds? So,
I'll tell you. He's incomparable to to
creation. So, there's another
hadith, I believe it's hadith, where
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
"I am to my creation similar I am to my
creation as he imagined me." So, what
that means is that if you were a
believer and you imagine Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala as being a merciful god,
then he will have mercy on you.
But if you're someone who didn't
uh believe in the mercy of Allah, you
despaired in the mercy of Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala. You believe that he was a
cruel god, then he's going to be cruel.
Um so, what essentially what it's saying
is don't ever despair in the mercy of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. That's what it
means when what the the nearest to the
picture they had.
No Muslim has a picture of Allah in
their head. I don't think that you
understand this. Look.
I don't think you understand [laughter]
it.
Uh I know. You want to force a literal
interpretation on it. That's the
problem. Let's Let's Let's see who which
one of us has a literal understanding.
Is it me or is it Muhammad? Look. During
the lifetime of of the prophet, some
people said, "Oh Allah's messenger,
shall we see our Lord on the Day of
Resurrection?" What are they asking? Are
they asking if they're going to
experience Allah's mercy or his
forgiveness? Or are they asking, "Hey,
man, are we going to see him?"
Yep, we're going to Are we going to see
him? Is that literal or is that
figurative?
No, that's literal. Okay. So, Muhammad
responds says, "Yes." So, you literally
will see Allah, correct?
Yeah.
All right. And you'll see him in a way
that does not limit him.
Oh,
nice. Awesome. We will see him in a way
that does not limit him. So, he can
appear to us in images or shapes that
coincide with our imagination, with our
minds that we pictured him to be.
This is literal, right?
We'll literally see him, yes. Yes. And
when we see him, how does he say that
you'll see him?
You will see him
as clear as the moon.
Yep, as clear as the moon.
You'll see him very clearly. All right,
good. And then he tells you exactly how
you're going to see him. Yep. He says,
"Then the Lord of the worlds will come
to them in a shape nearest to the
picture they had in their minds about
him." So, you're going to literally see
Allah how you imagined him to be.
If you imagine him to be man-like,
beast-like, beautiful, uh dark, maybe
some star shining light, this these are
the different shapes he's going to
appear to the different believers in the
that match their imagination.
Okay.
Okay. So, since we agree with this, it
doesn't say that Well, first of all, it
doesn't say that it will appear exactly
how they imagine. It says nearest to the
picture.
Sure.
>> want I just want to Yeah, right, right,
right. If they picture him with with
with two arms, he might come with one.
That's near
That's near enough to the picture.
>> [laughter]
>> Right. Okay. So, but at least we can
agree that they're actually going to
literally see him and he's actually
taking on shapes of creation, correct?
Well, I don't know if this
verse like this line here about him
taking on a near shape is in reference
to when we'll see him cuz you you did
skip over a lot of stuff.
Um
but all I know is that we will see him,
but it will be in a way
>> me?
We will see him, but it will be in a way
that does not limit his majesty or Are
you playing with me, bro?
No, man, I'm not playing with you. Are
you sure you're
I'm pretty sure. Why? It It said after
they asked about seeing their Lord, and
then Muhammad starts breaking it down
how they're going to see their Lord and
how he's going to
come to them.
Are we Are we
They really got you, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> You can think that. You can think that.
All right.
>> How did they get me? How did they get
me? They got you with that shahada. Once
that shahada happens, we call it an
Allah-botomy.
An Allah-botomy.
>> What does that mean?
>> [laughter]
>> It means exactly what it sounds like.
You know when you perform a lobotomy,
right? You do the procedure on the brain
and you kind of take the brain out and
stuff like that. That's what an Allah-
>> think they got you if you you know What
would you call that?
>> know. It's just funny how both sides
both sides think the other side's
brainwashed.
Which is so funny.
Well, you can definitely come back,
Aaron.
Um I like your I like your demeanor,
man. You got to be
Uh
well, you have your interpretations. I
can you know, you was honest to your
convictions.
Um but yeah, we got got we got to be
honest with the text. Got to be honest
with the text.
>> But I like I like I think I'm being
honest though cuz of those clear verses
like the the Quran You agree the Quran
says to to take the clear ones over the
ambiguous ones, right? The Quran says
that it's a detailed explanation of
everything, that everything's clear in
it. So, I'm convinced
>> No, it says it says in the Quran are
some verses that are clear and some that
are ambiguous.
>> it says that there are verses that the
Quran itself is a detailed explanation
of everything, that everything's clear,
so.
Yeah, it can be a a detailed
explanation, but some verses are clear
and some are ambiguous.
>> Wait, can it be a detailed explanation
of everything while having ambiguous
verses?
Yeah, why can't it be?
Why can't that be, Nick?
I I don't see the justification for it.
That's That's my issue.
The justification for what?
For what you just said. How exactly So,
when The Quran says that in there are
ambiguous verses and some are clear.
There's clear verses and ambiguous.
>> Okay, how do we know which is which?
Well, verses because in Arab in any
language, there are some words that only
have one meaning. There's not any other.
So,
Well, I'll grant you even in English
there are some sentences that only have
one possible meaning. Okay, so are you
saying that if a word has more than one
meaning, that cannot constitute one of
the clear verses?
So, I mean, not necessarily, but Okay,
so then that's not a justification for
it then.
How? I don't understand. Bro, because
you're saying I asked you, what is the
justification how we know something is
clear
versus something's ambiguous?
Well, there's obviously levels to it.
Okay, and you said your answer was
because some words just have one
meaning. But you just said even the
words that have multiple meaning can
still be part of the clear verses.
>> some words and it also some sentences
only have one meaning.
A sentence?
>> Like like if there's a sentence like
yeah, like for example, it says Allahu
ahad, like Allah is one. There's no
possible There's no other
interpretation.
>> because you can say we don't know what
he's one of. We don't know if he's
saying one person, one essence, etc. It
can mean multiple things.
But you know that he's one. One what?
It doesn't have to say what. We just
know that
>> So, we don't know. Exactly. See?
Okay, you guys are just being
ridiculous. Come on, Aaron.
You guys are actually ridiculous. This
is This is [laughter] serious. If you
say you're one, we don't know what
you're one of.
The The verse says that he is one.
There's no way you can interpret that as
not one.
It doesn't have
>> That's fine. We can interpret as one,
but what is he one of?
Uh you know what? I'll interpret that,
Aaron. I'll interpret that verse to say
he's one god, three persons. Amen.
Is that fair?
No.
>> It mean It can mean different things,
right?
Open to interpretation.
>> We can get in the whole argument, but I
think that saying three persons means
three gods.
Mhm.
All right. Well,
thank you, Aaron, for coming through,
man. You can definitely come back again.
Uh enjoyed your your demeanor, man. You
were respectful, you were lighthearted.
I like that. So, come back again, man,
okay? All right. All right. Take care.
>> All right. Have a nice day. Bye.